eeuu impone nuevas sanciones contra cuba
esa es la respuesta por los presuntos
abusos de derechos humanos cometidos en
las protestas antigubernamentales así lo
anunció el presidente joe biden en una
reunión con líderes cubanoamericanos en
la casa blanca
hoy estamos poniendo más sanciones
contra la policía nacional
revolucionaria así como sanciones
individuales contra el jefe y el subjefe
y continuaremos con las sanciones a
quienes cometan los abusos de su real
james spears y esto significa que sus
activos en eeuu quedarán congelados y
que no podrán hacer negocios con
empresas de ese país las sanciones se
suman a las de la semana pasada contra
el ministro de las fuerzas armadas de
cuba
álvaro lópez y el escuadrón elite más
conocido como boinas negras además
bailén afirmó que buscarían la manera
para brindar acceso a internet y
prometió ampliar la asistencia para los
presos políticos
pero lo que para el mandatario es una
atención a los reclamos de libertad para
el gobierno cubano es sólo una maniobra
política que necesita bailén
la reunión del presidente venden con
elección istas cubanos es una farsa para
justificar operación de cambio de
régimen versus cuba al gobierno de eeuu
sólo le interesa maquinaria electoral
florida mientras ignora reclamo del
pueblo cubano de los electores cubanos y
estadounidenses y del mundo en noviembre
de 2022 habrá elecciones en eeuu para
elegir a senadores y representantes a la
cámara y florida con un voto importante
de los cubanoamericanos es uno de los
bastiones en disputa